المترجم: Haneen Aljohany
المدقّق: Nada Qanbar
السلام عليكم جميعاً.
سأبدأ بسؤال
سؤال لكم جميعًا في هذه القاعة.
كم شخص يستيقظ في كل صباح
ويقوم بالنشاطات الأربعة التي سأذكرها:
طالب يذهب للمدرسة،
وشخص يقوم بتوصيل طالب لمدرسة،
وشخص يدرّس طلاب في مدرسة،
أو شخص يعمل في منظومة تعليمية.
بالنسبة لي، أقوم بتوصيل
أطفالي للمدرسة كل يوم.
لنرى كم شخص لدينا هنا اليوم في القاعة
يقوم بهذة الأدوار الأربعة كل يوم؟
جميل...جميل.
بالتأكيد نحن نقوم بهذه الأدوار كل صباح
ظناً منّا أننا نساهم في بناء المستقبل.
لكن إحصائيات اليوم تقول كلامًا مختلفًا.
تقول الإحصائيات أن 65% من الطلبة
في المراحل التعليمية قبل الجامعية،
سيعملون في وظائف مجهولة.
هذا يعني أن 65% من أطفالنا
مصيرهم مجهول.
لوهلة قد نظن أن هذا الكلام
نوع من أنواع الخيال العلمي.
لكن واقع اليوم أثبت لنا
أن الخيال العملي أمر سهل تحقيقه.
مثال، ومثال كلنا نعرفه،
فلم "الرجل الحديدي."
في أول عرض للفلم،
وعلى وجه التحديد البدلة الذكية.
عندما رأيناها لأول مرة كلنا قلنا:
"واو، شيء عجيب."
وعندما انتهى الفيلم، قلنا جميعًا
هذا الأمر مستحيل وصعب التحقيق.
اليوم أطفالنا في منطقة الخليج الغربي
يلعبون في الماء ويلبسون بدلات مائية
تستخدم نفس تلك التقنيات.
هذه هي قوة الخيال العلمي
وهذه هي سهولة تحقيقه.
الآن، هل يمكننا التخيل كيف للتكنولوجيا
أن تدخل في قطاع ما وتغيره تمامًا؟
وتغير مفهوم الوظيفة والعمل فيه؟
دعونا نأخذ قطاع واحد على سبيل المثال،
القطاع الإنشائي أو قطاع البنيان.
ودعونا كلنا مع بعض نذهب في رحلة
أننا سنبني بيتًا.
نحن نعرف بأن عملية بناء البيت
تعتمد على جزئين:
الجزء الأول التصميم،
والجزء الثاني التنفيذ.
التصميم اليوم أنا أذهب
إلى المهندس المدني أو المعماري،
أعطي ملاحظاتي وتصوري عن البيت،
وهو بدوره يرسم التصميم ويعطيني الخرائط.
هذه العملية كلها
يتم استبدالها بالذكاء الاصطناعي.
الذكاء الاصطناعي: عبارة عن عملية
يتم فيها مراجعة البيانات
بسرعة عالية جداً وبدقة عالية جدًا،
من خلالها يمكننا أن نتنبأ بالمستقبل.
فدعونا نتخيل أننا أمام
جهاز الذكاء الاصطناعي،
لنقل أنني أريد بناء بيت،
الجهاز على اطلاع على كل معلوماتي،
الأشياء التي أحبها والتي لا أحبها.
يعرف زوجتي وهو يعرف كل معلوماتها،
بناءً على كل المعلومات الموجودة
وعلى الطلب هذا
يستطيع الجهاز التنبأ بشكل التصميم
الذي خطر في مخيلتنا.
ممكن أن ننزل التصميم على جهاز الآيباد،
ونضعه على قطعة الأرض التي سنبني عليها.
وسنرى البيت بالكامل.
يمكن أن نرى الغرف والتوزيع
والألوان والأثاث،
ونبدي رأينا فيه.
لننتقل الآن للجزء الثاني من بناء البيت،
التنفيذ.
بناء البيت اليوم يعتمد على المهندس المدني،
والعمال الذين معه
ويشتغلون بالنجارة والحدادة والأسمنت
حتى ينتهوا من بناء البيت.
العملية هذه بالكامل يتم استبدالها
بطابعة ثلاثية الأبعاد.
طابعة تطبع البيت طباعة
بدقة أعلى، بسرعة أعلى،
وأمان أفضل.
الآن، إذا كان يوجد أي شخص بالقاعة،
يفكر أنه يصبح مهندس مدني
أو يكون مصمم.
أتمنى أن يعيد التفكير في قراره.
هذه فكرة الإنسان يحولها لمنتج ملموس،
الناس تشعر بحاجتها للمنتج،
ومستعدين يدفعون فيها قيمة مالية.
هذه هي أساس فكرة
اقتصاد قائم على المعرفة.
أنه كيف الإنسان يحول معرفته
لمنتج ملموس
والناس مستعدة تدفع فيه قيمة.
الآن يبقى السؤال،
كيف نبني هذا النوع من الاقتصاد؟
إذا رأينا الدول الكبيرة
التي اقتصادها قائم على المعرفة
فتحت هذه الدول مساحة جديدة
للتعليم الإبداعي
هذه الدول هجرت التعليم التقليدي
التعليم الذي فلسفته قائمة
على أن المدرس هو مصدر المعرفة والعلم.
التعليم الذي فلسفته قائمة على أن
المعرفة والعلم حكرًا فقط على الصف الدراسي.
الدول هذه فتحت مجال
مساحات جديدة للتعليم،
تستثير السؤال في عقل الطالب،
وتعطيه مساحة ليبحث عن الجواب
ويعمل شيء بيده.
الآن، يبقى السؤال
كيف التعليم الإبداعي هذا
يساعد في قضية الوظائف المجهولة
في المستقبل؟
مخرجات التعليم الإبداعي تشكل
ناس قادرين يتعاملون مع البيئة حولهم
قادرين أنهم يضعون حلول
للتحديات والمشاكل التي تواجههم.
الآن، كل الذي أتحدث عنه يحدث
في العالم الخارجي
أين قطر من كل هذا؟
نحن كلنا نعلم أن قطر دولة صغيرة
تعتمد بشكل كبير على مواردها الطبيعية
البترول والغاز.
لكنها قررت أن يكون لديها
اقتصاد قائم على المعرفة.
اقتصاد يعتمد على تعدد
مصادر الدخل في الدولة
قطر بدأت في المجال هذا،
فتحت مساحة على أساس أن يصبح عندنا
تعليم إبداعي مبتكر،
وأعطت مساحة لمبادرات تعليمية
وبرامج تعليمية
ومشاريع تعليمية.
واحدة منهم "مبادرة صانع."
مبادرة صانع هي مبادرة هدفها
نشر ثقافة صنع الابتكار في المجتمع المحلي.
كيف اليوم نمكن الفرد عندنا في قطر
أنه يحول الفكرة إلى منتج ملموس؟
المبادرة عبارة عن مظلة
تحتها مجموعة مشاريع:
مسابقة صانع، باص صانع،
منهج صانع، متجر صانع.
الآن يبقى السؤال
ما هو الأثر على أفرادها؟
واحد من الطلبة دخل معنا
في مسابقة صانع من سنتين،
كان يلاحظ مشكلة كبيرة في المجتمع القطري
في قضية استهلاك الماء،
ونسبة كبيرة من الماء المستهلك
يذهب للمجاري.
ففكر لماذا لا أبني منتج يركب
على قناة المجاري،
ويحول الطاقة الحركية للماء
إلى طاقة كهربائية
لنعيد استخدامها في البيت مرة أخرى.
عندما انتهى الطالب من الثانوية
قرر أن يدرس الميكاترونكس.
الميكاترونكس هو علم يدمج
الهندسة الميكانيكية بالهندسة الالكترونية.
التخصص هذا غير مرغوب في السوق العمل عندنا
لكن بدون أدنى شك
التخصص هذا يحاكي لغة المستقبل.
مثال آخر، مشروع آخر
طالب آخر دخل معنا في المسابقة
السنة الماضية،
كان يلاحظ عندما يذهب مع زملاؤه الطلاب
لمعامل الأحياء ويقوموا بتجارب
على الخلايا ويستخدموا التلسكوب العلمي،
انتبه أن كل زملاؤه يضعون أعينهم
على التلسكوب
فاستثاره سؤال، قال أحد من زملائه
عنده رمد في عينه أو حساسية
فما أثر هذا على باقي الزملاء؟
فالملاحظة واستثارة السؤال
أتى في باله فكرة منتج،
عبارة عن كيس تلفون
يركبه على عدسة التلسكوب
ويضع عليه الهاتف الذكي.
وطبعا هنا ماذا استطاع أن يفعل؟
هو استطاع أن يوفر محتوى لحظي رقمي
فيديو وصور،
ويشاركه مع كل زملائه بالبيئة المدرسية.
في نفس الجهاز هذا موجود في السوق
قيمته 2300 دولار
تلسكوب علمي رقمي.
الكيس هذا على تقدير الطلبة
تكلفته أقل من 30 دولار
اليوم،
كثير من الناس تسألني ما هي مخرجات صانع؟
ماهي منتجات صانع؟
ما هي اختراعات صانع؟
أنا أقول لهم: مخرجات صانع، ومنتجات صانع
هي بالمعلمين والطلبة الذين دخلوا
معنا بتجربة صانع
وتمكنوا بعد التجربة أن يحولوا
أفكارهم إلى منتجات ملموسة.
أن يحولوا أفكارهم إلى منتجات ملموسة.
اليوم أنا أقف أمامكم وكلّي ثقة
بأن قضية بناء اقتصاد قائم على المعرفة
عندنا في قطر أمر ممكن وممكن جدًا.
لكن يحتاج القليل من الوقت
مثل ما تغيير الإنسان يحتاج إلى الوقت
نمو النبتة يحتاج إلى الوقت.
وإدخال ثقافة جديدة على المجتمع
يحتاج إلى الوقت، والقليل من الوقت.
قطر بمواردها الطبيعية
ممكن أن تعيش 150 سنة،
لكن الاستثمار في رأس المال البشري
نحن ممكن نعيش 1500 سنة.
شكرًا.
(تصفيق)